ni on va faire un jeu culture générale
et aventure et défis 200 personnes ont
parlé de 200 personnes au public bonjour
cinq cent mille euros de cadeaux
et de 500000 euros de cadeaux ah ouais
énorme ça veut dire tu rentres chez toi
c'est fini tu as dit elle est faite à
partager également peut-être même avec
un à un une maison à gagner tous ces
tournois mais on voit tron tout bateau
la fille de benjamin castaldi ya 20 ans
[Rires]
on en est on aujourd'hui est la vôtre
aujourd'hui
une box et ça va partir de là
les chiffres donc la très simple année
200 plateaux et la question de culture
générale il y en a trente qui vont
sortir ils vont partir dans un bus
ils partent dans un bus des questions
des défis à chaque fois que la personne
perd on la laisse sur le bord de la
route avec ses parents arrivés en corse
ou perdront donc alors s'en attendait
puisque là c'est la première étape donc
le bus stac les gens sortent il n'en
reste plus que 15 48 tomba sur un bateau
sur un bateau pareil tout
avec sa valise sur pied une nouvelle
relation peu mais on se démerde serez
après on termine à 5 et on est dans un
avion et ami de m
les trois qui perdent saute en parachute
johnny en parachute le dernier on arrive
en corse on est sur une falaise sur tous
les jeux accrochés soit l'élastique le
perdant de la finale saut à l'élastique
et l'autre est et gagnent les 500000
euros de cadeaux
je vais dans le monde entier et ses
manies dans le monde entier au bout de
combien de décès en des programmes
alors vraiment joli ça va arriver à la
rentrée on se projeter vite là on est en
avance avait coûté cher ça les maires je
n'ai pas un pro mais aussi non mais si
ça va être beau ça va être beau je viens
là dessus et je le dis machi présent je
ne gagne pas un euro voilà je le dis sur
7 et sur soie lavée perd de l'argent à
tuer les gens n'ont plus l'envié aux que
voilà oui mais la maison est bouleversée
en 30e salon les beignets
jeu moi je suis pas là dedans a lâché
dans le programme arrêté la station vous
êtes que sur lausanne en faire autant et
c'est un sou
pendaison va le faire sourire je suivais
le propose à canal+ avec hervé mathoux
ou bien on va le faire sur seignal avec
m votre serviteur voilà donc et voilà
vous ça vous plaît c'est plein de
projets non
non non c'est déjà accepté par ses beats
c'est déjà accepté et m'a vendu où il
s'est fait on le force voilà oui senna
au classement de la démarrer oui ça va
démarrer oui voilà qu'il le veuille si
canal le vote a fait un truc bien calme
lundi les créations cana sur une raideur
et hervé serait excellent ben voilà donc
antoine ça vous plaît ben c'est pas mal
ça c'est pas mal j'aime faire démonter
non non c'est vachement bien non mais
dis moi je n'aime pas on s'en fout ça
rigolo jeu j j'essayais d'imaginer le
mettre en balance dans la mer avec sa
valise
lui qui avait que c'est pas une question
pas le
kilomètre
c'est d'imaginer tous ces trucs à peine
au dessus soit je suis assez bien c'est
pas madame soleil c'est que tout est
bien cmrc crescendo au début tu dégages
du cadre du bus est toute douce amère
sang prélevé
pour la nationale
ça à fond c'est un truc que j'ai en tête
voilà depuis comment vous l'appelez puis
de moi j'ai pas encore le nom j'ai pas
encore le nom ipad ou encore non non non
ça va déjà on fait des missions
affrontera le nom mais vous ne ferez pas
le faire vous j'aime bien j'aime bien et
ça me ferait plaisir qu'il soit hervé
aussi vous savez moi je suis
particulièrement qui voici jamais voilà
ça me ferait marrer le faire mais moi
ici il faut que je trouve le temps voit
ce que ça donne quoi je vous rappelle